welcome everyone is saint paganotti
today I speak of poles for polymer is one
platform that allows today
using the implementation of wood
component is very high
within your system
developed the saint pin web applications
a little differently than how
let's imagine living polymers today
levels the first called fondation is
basically a collection of
policy and therefore of libraries that
compensate for potential deficiencies of the
browser against new ones
html5 specifications and contains a series of
own information and functionality
of the framework and therefore give us
precisely all the tools for
use this this catch that
I believe this technology and elements
instead contains a collection of
elements we can use
combine to build our everything
poli mea was born around the concept of
morcone and therefore the possibility of
build your own of clear elements
for example of the new html tags but
also operational features e
mix and match these elements e
very important thing and distribute
these elements and to use them in
applications
this is in a nutshell what
let's look at how we build today
how can we build our own
component benefiting from some
components already present in the collection
in the collection elements of pollina that
it is offered to us first of all
is a commitment of the new folder
let's proceed with the installation of
polymer we use boer than a package
javascript manager and let's use it
then invoking its instant function
on the pollica polymer platform library
and volley cal poly awakens
an ok installation once done
we build a new element
new file and sorry that will be the
container of our element then
we can call it
sp wall ok dot happens in mind
among the various features it can
food 200 web development there is also the
possibility to use the link to
include html pages in html page
this syntax is foreseen from point c
no browser is simulated yet
thanks precisely to the use of the poles
film of the foundation section and in
this case the inside of the master file
and people
we are going to close the basic component of
polymer which is what helps us then
develop our entire application
and also let's use a
other polymer component that a
element of poles but which gives us a hand
in the area it retrieves information from
pd remote services through ajax is a
component already developed is called poly
verjux and we do not introduce this
simple inclusion after being there
remember to have it installed because i
individual components must be
also installed and in this case
also let's use as already done
previously the same google for which
bonini star polymer ajax and how
result installation in the presence of
this component we serve and it
development of our component every
polymer component differs from
syntax pole but complaining let's go to
define the name of our element e
we can define as in this case
come here with other boots if the item
weeks we are defining will have
of attributes and to which variable
internal this tribute will have to be
associated so we expect a
query attribute and attribute here
will be associated with workable inter
languish as he saw fracts
after doing this obviously
we must always remember to close
the element polymer element then
let's close the polymeric element
and once this is done we can
proceed with the same of the temples in
this case our element where
go buy a list of videos from
youtube and print them as a list for
which we are going to do
defined a template within the
which we will go naked or in serious and
simply a list of elements ok
then murelle and within this one
list of items we will use again
the template tag this time with a
practical function reads like a tribute
particular is called di pitt e si
continues a certain dexterity with
the use of the template recognizes
quietly this double parenthesis
gafà which means inclusion of a given
dynamic and therefore in this case we will go
repeat for each element of the set
of the rai videos prints the title of
this video is very important thing to
remember in poles but is the president
binding between what our team is
of bindings with our time has given
so now I have to update video
immediately the teams not updated in
template once this is done let's go
to use the polymer component for
the query through ajax
component that we do not write but
that we have centered within the
of the pole library but between the
elements of poly me is simply it
with let alone with our need
so I love to say that the component
poles but jax
that will return to the jasons of the team
fiona those made on youtube videos
we are going to specify we also note in
this case the notation with double
braces to the item q in this
so we are saying that the value
of the variable that must be
used as a tribute qe we ask
who helped be managed as jason e
which was called a charge function
video upon receipt of this feed
done this we close ours
template ok and we have to go to manage
all the dynamic part so this
template obviously has its own for
display some of its components
internal but for example the charge function
the video we call upon here
obviously to be managed to do
we use a very simple tag
script always inside the polymer
lemont this tweet tags like it
involves good polymer part precisely
of the framework functions in this
case we define the element that sp wall
element is composed of a variable a
internal attribute called videos
which happens to be what we go
use within our cycle
here you see credit videos in videos and
videos is defined by default as in
empty and one that enhances gods
default with dumbo death but it is
obviously this enhancement will come
signed by the value to come
those in the tribute passed into the
element declaration and has a
function loads the video that is
worries about receiving the result of
ajax relation on this endpoint and in
particular to extract from this
video interrogation is standard
the internal video variable being there
light binding does not interest us when
this function the call as
once the variable of
spunto videos we will observe in chain
update the repopulate page
precisely the page with the list of videos
of research once this is done
our complete element contains everything
what interests us is one of itself
used on the page
so we expect a lot of index.html
very simple is structured as follows
a doctype the request to ours
anger towards our platformer file
of blair that basically introduces
all the phil poles needed for the
behavior of the behavior of
this of this demo and all the
applications that we would like to do with
policy let's use the import tag
and let's include our element
which in turn by closing the
elements on which it depends and we use the
cement sp wall with a different from then
in this case nirvana and what there is
expect we expect the item
once in the page it is replaced
with the associated anes template we do
a test we carry on our own
index update to the page and behold
precisely the list of the first results
in the query to youtube of con
the eagle the nirvana but there is more
if we move on to spector and ci
we lose in the console
if we go to target our
item by tag so
sp bull ok ok let's hear about targeting
our element we note that the following
obviously it exists if we go to
edit attribute in our query
item for example going to use
chrome as a word like clear of
research what happens is that
the list is automatically updated with
the new values ​​said nothing
from the attribute just modified this
thanks to the tadi function from the meeting of
live binding has previously we say
introduced this is all I hope to
intrigued enough and pollen
still in the state of pre alpha but vi
I highly recommend giving it
quick View
See you soon